how do you give your images that vintage
look
welcome to make with me i'm matthew
encina and yes
me are my initials in this tutorial i'll
show you how to take your images and age
them in photoshop
using a few simple techniques let's get
into it
[Music]
so i have my artwork here this is just
a stock photo that i grabbed from
shutterstock and i overlaid the type
vintage using the typeface futura
the first thing i want to do is add a
paper texture
and the reason why i want to do that is
normally with a lot of these
old photos or old posters
they were printed they weren't digital
what i'm looking for is a
texture like this one that i can
composite on top of here
so i'm gonna just drop this on top of
the image so i have this nice
paper texture that's warm has all these
cool little imperfections and fibers in
there
and i'm just going to name this paper
texture and i'm going to change the
blend mode over here to multiply
so what this is doing is it's taking all
of the dark values of the image of the
paper texture
and compositing that on top of all the
artwork
underneath so now i have my initial
texture on top and it's already looking
pretty good it's already halfway there i
think
with this paper texture so the next
thing i want to do
is add some dust and dirt so again i'm
going to go to my
folder and if you look at any aged
photographs if you leave it out long
enough it will collect
dust and dirt either on the film or
on the the print itself so what i'm
looking
for is another thing ah this looks
pretty cool and this one looks right
so i'm just looking for something that
has these cool little specks of dust and
lint just to give it again more of that
weathered look
and i'm gonna rename this to dust and
dirt
i am actually going to invert it by
pushing command
i or control i and this is going to
reverse the values here so now i want to
have these dark
little specks to be multiplied on top so
i'm going to go to the blend mode here
again
go to multiply and it already gives all
this dust and dirt on there but i think
it's a little strong so i'm going to
bring it down
so i'm going to push command m or
control m if you're on pc
and what i want to do is i want to lift
the dark values
so they start to disappear so if i just
make a point here and i still
pull this up you can see what that's
doing to that dust and dirt layer if i
bring it down it's going to do the
reverse and bring
more dirt on top so i feel like this is
pretty good
so you can see this before and after i
still think it's a little strong in
certain areas specifically over her face
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make a mask layer mask right here
i'm going to push b for brush and i'm
going to make sure i have a black value
and i'm just going to paint out a few
areas on her face where i don't want the
dust to appear
before i do that i'm going to push shift
1 to change the flow of the brush to
10 so it's really light and i could take
my time and be pretty subtle with this
so
as you can see i'm slowly erasing some
of the dust and dirt
on her face because i want her face to
pop out and i don't really want it to be
affected by all the dirt and then same
with her shirt here and her chin
so i'm just painting out a few of these
areas because i think
it looks a little bit better so i'm
pretty happy with that
and that is the dust and dirt okay the
next thing i want to do is add
scratches to this image so if you leave
a photo or print out long enough and you
let it get
banged up in your closet or in the box
it tends to get scratches so
what i'm looking for is another texture
layer
to add scratches and i found this one on
shutterstock that i really like so it
has these cool creases here
and all of these white little nicks so
i'm going to grab this
drop this on top and then i'm going to
push enter and i'm going to name this
scratches then i'm going to go to the
blend mode and instead of multiply i'm
going to go screen
so screen is the opposite of multiply
screen
takes the light values of an image and
then composites
it on top of everything below it took
all those
white scratches and folds and it's
compositing it on top
and this looks pretty cool i like it but
just like the dust and dirt i feel like
it's a little strong for me i don't like
how faded it looks in
some of these areas so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to
push command m adjust the curves again
and i'm just going to bring this down
so i'm going to bring down the white
levels a little bit and you can see it's
starting to
preserve some of the white specks that i
have
there we go so the next thing i want to
do
is add a little bit of aging so if you
leave your prints out long enough
and you leave it in the sun the edges
tend to fade the color
tends to desaturate a little bit or get
warped and changed
so what i want to do is i'm going to
create a new layer and you'll see what
i'm about to do in a minute i'm going to
push b for brush
and i'm going to select two different
colors here first i'm going to go to a
warm value here that's
bright a little bit more on the orange
side to replicate like a
bright sun and i'm just going to paint
that over this edge right here
and then i'm going to take the opposite
a cool color a complementary color
that's a little bit darker
maybe more in the mid values around here
and i'm going to paint this area here
and again i'm just trying to emulate
what happens when you leave
a photo out in the sun for too long
the colors change and fade so i'm going
to go over to my blend mode
but instead of changing it to multiply
or screen i'm going to change it to soft
light
and i use this blend mode to add
contrast to my images
and what it does is it takes values that
are 50 percent and brighter
and then lightens the image and then it
takes values that are 50
and darker and darkens those so you can
see the difference of that
before and after so i'm gonna just turn
that down just a
touch because i think it's a little
strong i feel like i faded her face a
little too much
so what i'm gonna do is i'm going to
take
a dark orange
something like this let me play with
this let me see what happens and if i
paint this on her face yeah there we go
so what it's doing is it's adding a
little bit of contrast
just to her face so if we turn off the
blend mode you can see
i'm just adding a little bit of darkness
right here and again it's multiplying
that on top
which is giving it contrast so if i go
back to soft light
you can see what that looks like before
and after
now i feel pretty good about that i like
that a lot okay so the next thing i want
to do is i want to color grade the
photo a little bit and if you ever look
at any old vintage photos or prints
sometimes the dark areas of
a photos seem to be a little bit warmer
and then the white areas
either they tint a little bit cooler or
they tint a little bit warmer
at any rate i just want to play with a
little color grading where i'm stylizing
the color of this photo
so i'm going to create a new curves here
i'm going to call this color grade and
then i'm going to go to the reds
here so i'm going to take the dark
values of the reds and see what happens
if i just
were to lift that up so you can see in
the dark values of the red there i don't
like what it's doing
in the all the medium and bright values
i'm going to bring that back down
just a touch so i'm just right now i'm
just adjusting
the darks adding a little bit more red
to that and i want that to look a little
bit more brown
i'm going to add a little bit of green
to that as well so now you can see it's
those blacks are a little bit more brown
there if i pull this
back a little bit you can see i'm adding
a little bit of a green tint
into the highlights now if i go to the
blue let me try the same thing here and
add a little bit of blue
to the highlights not too much but i'm
going to bring it down
elsewhere so it has a little bit more of
a yellow tint
so let's see that off and then on
so you can see i added a little bit of a
brown tint
to the dark values and i gave a little
bit of
this greenish blue wash on
the highlights so i'm feeling pretty
good you can see what this looks like
before
and after and i'm just gonna take all of
my layers that i added
i'm gonna put them in folder and call
them effects
just so we could see quickly before
and after feels pretty good so far the
next thing
i want to do is add some soft edges
to my artwork here and if you ever look
at old photos they tend to get very soft
around the edges of the lens or the
frame
so i want to emulate that a bit so i'm
going to take my artwork and i'm going
to convert that
into a smart layer so convert for smart
filters
now that it's a smart layer i'm going to
go to filter
blur gallery and iris blur
just so that i can mimic the blur around
the edges and you can see what it's
doing here to the letters
e and v which is pretty cool i think
that's a little strong for my taste so
i'm gonna open this up and just
have it barely on the edge i like that
look
let me press okay okay
that looks pretty cool i feel pretty
close to done here
what i want to do is i want to add a
little bit of grain to this photo
the photo looks super clean because it's
a beautifully shot stock photo
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
add a new layer i'm going to call it
grain
and i'm just going to fill this with 50
gray essentially
and then i'm going to go to filter noise
add noise
so i have this cool noise right here i'm
just setting it to gaussian
then monochromatic i'm going to put okay
and then i'm going to go to my grain and
i'm going to change
the blend mode to soft light and if we
look very closely that has such
a great effect on it see that
this is before and then after
now it kind of looks like this was
printed inside of a book and it has that
natural grain that would come from a
high resolution print
and that's pretty much it of course this
is a great way to give
your images that aged vintage look
but also practice restraint it's very
easy to go overboard
in doing this stuff it's easy to make
your images look too muddy
or too dirty and i tend to do that from
time to time because it's so much fun
adding all this texture
but use restraint and only use it where
it's appropriate hopefully that was
helpful so you can see
where we started and then after our
effects
this is what it looks like
that's the end of our tutorial if you
enjoyed this and want to see more
let us know by hitting the subscribe
button and then leaving us a comment on
what you'd like me to cover next if you
want to learn my entire image making
process from
concept research to design and
presentation
check out my course on style frames
where i teach you photo manipulation
and how to tell stories with single
images
that's it for me i'll see you in the
future